vous avez pensé de la triche de thé
world
franchement pas franchement sert il oui
on est affamé ouais n'importe quelle
personne être humain normal tu es
affamés sénile mais je suis toujours été
opposé à manger à une année active à la
vie vaut mieux de l'anah qui court chez
mon chaton chocolat soit
là mais tu sais vous connaissez pas la
vraie fan c'est souvent maintenant on
entend la fin janvier pas pris mon petit
déjeuner j'ai pas pris mon petit
déjeuner j'ai faim j'ai non la vraie fin
c'est quand on vend trith pas à nos
débuts après surplus après tout m d'ils
après ton ventes atteint souvent bien
trente jours qui arrivent et qui donne à
manger je bave bien sûr tu le prendre
mais franchement faut arrêter du jeu de
mail algérois fin savoir si je fais koh
lanta jamais d'un gars de des libéraux
et moi
non mais il ya un truc qu'il faut savoir
c'est que la colle en passe 80 % de
notre temps à chercher à manger mais je
suis un juif qui traîne mais moi je suis
même pas sûr que l'otage parce 80%
succès
dans la vie normale
c'est vrai
vous ne voulez pas naba n'ont pas déjà
fait j'ai fait pareil ou pas mais
honnêtement c'est dur de répondre à
cette question mais je pense que oui je
pense que si j'avais trouvé à manger
j'aurais manche alors qu'il a pas qu il
a fait beau dit comment
devrait vraiment on pense qu'à ça
tranquille sur koh lanta quoi toi non
mais c'est vrai moi sincèrement s'il a
touché le code et tout
ça sans m'en suis sorti au bon moment
parce que si j'avais été dans le jeu je
pense que j'aurais mangé avec le groupe
a tiré sur ben c'est surtout pour donner
je vous reconnais humoristes vous avez
mangé sans moi aussi mais ouais seraient
mangés ouais bah oui ouais nan mais je
vous assure ne connaissait pas la vraie
fin mai un crs est vraiment annoncé
c'est un enfer son plein tu vois la télé
coaching salomon d'être mais tu tentes
qui n'a pas vécu tu peux pas comprendre
la cen-sad c'est vrai maintenant c'est
le pire vraiment horrible il devient
femme et c'est vraiment la bouffe tu
deviens parano
je sais personnellement même la nuit
j'en rêvais je vais rêver qu'on est tous
là ensemble mais il y aura un buffet
chinois lie alors burger si vraiment ça
y est on parle que de ça c'est vrai
c'est ouf elles sont ignorés propose à
plumes par la berge sur koh lanta sont
20 mai prochain tué ma mère est pierre
mongin
fédérer avait dû m'entraîner le pas avec
ma mère tu perds tu produis kg non mais
je te jure avait cherché des tons la
fédé complétons ont détruit vous aimez
quand même cette aventure ah oui oui
plus que tout quatre fois refoulé mais
puisque les mêmes mais avant de partir
est ce qu'on a une petite race sera de
se dire ça va être très dur on va pas
manger on va galérer non moi
personnellement non parce que je suis
pas un gros mangeur mois d'autant plus
que du coup j'ai sous-estimé la
nourriture mais je m'étais dit je
pensais que ce serait plus dur entre
guillemets physiquement par rapport à la
nourriture alors qu'en fait c'est
vraiment la nourriture qui nous qui nous
conditionnent